Salut les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux
vous reconnaissez ?
C'est le drapeau des États-Unis
et qui dit États-Unis, dit rock 'n' roll,
baseball, super-héros, conquête spatiale
et bien sûr hamburger.
Aujourd'hui, je vous raconte d'où il vient
et pourquoi il a toujours l'air
plus appétissant en photo qu'en réalité.
J'espère que vous allez digérer
la réponse.
L'histoire du hamburger,
c'est avant tout un voyage,
un voyage qui ne commence pas en direction
de la Floride ou de la Californie,
mais en direction de l'Asie, de la Mongolie
précisément.
Tu veux dire que le hamburger
ne serait pas américain,
mais mongol ?
Pas complètement, mais un peu quand même.
Cheese !
J'explique. A la fin du XIème siècle,
Gengis Khan réussit à unifier
tous les clans mongols
et se lance dans la conquête
de nouveaux territoires. A son apogée,
son empire s'étendra depuis la Mer de
Chine jusqu'aux Pays baltes.
Grâce à des cavaliers hors pair,
Gengis Khan sème la terreur sur des millions de kilomètres carrés.
Entre chaque bataille,
ses guerriers et leurs montures
avalent des kilomètres.
Ils ne prennent même pas le temps
de s'arrêter manger.
Les soldats se nourrissent de fines
tranches de viande crue
qu'ils ingurgitent durant leur chevauchée.
Mais avant de l'avaler,
la viande est glissée sous la selle,
ce qui permet de l'attendrir et d'y
avoir accès sans mettre le pied à terre.
Une habitude qu'ils ont encore
lorsqu'ils envahissent Moscou en 1238.
Du coup, les Russes adoptent cette viande
qui, à force
d'être triturée dans tous les sens,
finit par être hachée.
Et comme les envahisseurs
appartiennent à la tribu des Tatars,
on lui donne le même nom.
Le steak tatars qui deviendra tartare
vient de naître.
Qui l'eût cru.
Au fil du temps,
la viande crue s'enrichit de lait,
d'oignons,
d'œufs crus,
elle circule dans toute l'Europe.
Elle passe par le port d'Hambourg,
dans le nord de l'Allemagne.
C'est là qu'au XVIIIᵉ siècle, un boucher
a l'idée de mettre la viande crue
sur le gril. C'est bon.
Il vient de créer le steak de
Hambourg, le hamburger steak.
Je vous mâche un peu le travail là.
Au XIXᵉ siècle,
près de 4 millions d'Allemands
quittent leur pays
pour participer au rêve américain.
Dans les bagages des migrants, on trouve
beaucoup d'espoir et aussi le fameux
Hamburger Steak.
Pas que la recette,
le hamburger en chair et en os.
Enfin, surtout en chair.
Il sert de nourriture
pendant la traversée.
La viande est salée, mélangée
à des oignons, parfois de la chapelure,
et également fumée pour pouvoir
être conservée plus longtemps.
Mais alors, qui a eu l'idée géniale
d'ajouter deux tranches de pain ?
Eh bien, c'est là que ça se complique.
7 américains revendiquent cette idée.
Ça fait une belle brochette.
Oui, mais un peu indigeste.
Le sandwich, considéré
comme une innovation majeure, est présenté
au public lors de l'Exposition
universelle de Saint-Louis en 1904.
Et c'est le début
d'une incroyable success story.
En 1931, Popeye,
le héros de la bande dessinée du même nom.
grand amateur d'épinards, croise
un nouveau personnage,
un certain Wimpy
qui, lui, adore les hamburgers.
Le personnage plaît tant qu'une
chaîne de restaurants prend son nom.
Wimpy's.
Bah,
je trouve pas l'adresse.
Normal ! Comme l'avait souhaité
le fondateur de la chaîne,
tous les restaurants
ont été fermés à sa mort en 1978.
Une petite dernière pour la route.
En 1940, à San Bernardino, en Californie,
deux frères ouvrent une gargote
spécialisée dans la vente de hamburgers.
Les sandwichs se vendent comme
des petits pains. Pour réduire les coûts,
Maurice et Richard McDonald
ont créé un self-service.
Big success!
Allez, direction la cuisine.
Avec le temps,
la recette du hamburger a évolué.
Le pain brioché est toujours là, mais
la viande de boeuf haché, pas toujours.
On peut y trouver du poulet, du poisson.
En Suède, sur la petite île de Vaxholm,
j'en ai même mangé un avec du hareng.
Mais un seul.
Certains hamburgers ne contiennent même
plus du tout de viande.
Il y a une galette de légumes à la place.
Vous pouvez y ajouter du bacon,
des sauces,
des tomates quand c'est
la saison, des cornichons et du fromage.
Et là, les 1200 variétés de fromage
français sont les bienvenues.
Et vous, comment l'aimez-vous?
N'hésitez pas à laisser
votre recette en commentaire.
Le hamburger, vous pouvez en manger
pour quelques euros
ou quelques dollars au coin de la rue,
mais ça peut grimper jusqu'à 3800€.
Pardon ?
Oui, oui, tu as bien entendu !
Dans un restaurant de Las Vegas,
il faut débourser 3786€
pour déguster le Fleur Burger.
Mais il fait combien d'étages?
Il est surtout composé de bœuf de Kobé,
de foie gras et de truffes noires.
Le pain brioché, quant à lui,
est nappé d'une sauce aux truffes.
Bon, c'est vrai, toi,
t'es un peu pâlot à côté.
Il faut dire que le hamburger
sur les photos publicitaires
est toujours plus appétissant
que celui qui arrive dans notre assiette.
Et c'est un peu normal.
La photo est minutieusement travaillée,
les ingrédients sont retouchés.
Ils ont droit à leur petite touche
de maquillage.
un peu de matifiant par-ci,
un peu de brillance par-là
pour que chacun des ingrédients soit mis
en valeur et facilement identifiable.
L'appétit, c'est bien connu,
passe aussi par la vue.
Mais il y a une autre raison
que les chaînes de restaurants
qui font de la vente à emporter évoquent
les hamburgers, sont distribués
dans des boîtes cartonnées.
Ils ont été mis encore chauds,
parfois emmaillotés,
dans une feuille de papier
légèrement plastifiée.
L'objectif
est de maintenir leur température.
Mais cet emballage est assez hermétique
et il empêche la dispersion de la vapeur
contenue dans les aliments.
Elles s'accumulent dans le pain
qui a tendance à s'écraser
sous le poids de l'humidité.
La salade perd son croquant
et le fromage s'étale sur les côtés.
Bon, tu es un peu moins beau qu'en photo.
Mais vu l'heure,
il va quand même passer à la casserole.
Parti des steppes de Mongolie,
le hamburger est aujourd'hui
partout, jusque sur mon bar.
Il a même sa propre journée mondiale,
le 13 octobre.
Mais ce sandwich est aussi
une histoire de chiffres
plus impressionnants
les uns que les autres.
Les Américains sont
les maîtres incontestés de la consommation
de hamburgers.
Chaque année, ils en mangent 50 milliards.
J'ai fait le calcul à raison
de 328 millions d'habitants.
Ça fait trois burgers par personne
et par semaine.
Allez, un autre chiffre 913.
913 kg, c'est le poids du plus gros
hamburger du monde.
Il a été confectionné par un casino
de Minnesota, aux Etats-Unis, en 2012.
Et puis, je ne peux pas finir cette vidéo
sans parler
du drame national
que nous avons vécu en 2017.
Notre célèbre jambon-beurre
a été détrôné par le hamburger américain.
Cette année-là,
les Français ont consommé
1,4 milliard de burgers, 200000 de plus
que le jambon-beurre.
Un drame, vous dis-je.
Mais bon, il n'appartient qu'à
nous d'inverser la tendance.
Allez ne fais pas la tête.
Je vais te manger,
juste le temps de saluer les Epicurieuses
et les Epicurieux. A très bientôt.